hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to subnautica now you
may be wondering why we are standing in
the shadow of the Aurora and I'll tell
you one thing that's very important
because I know I said I was going to be
going down into the lava zone and I am
NOT a liar we are going to be going down
there very soon but before we do that
I've been informed that in this ship is
something that I absolutely cannot leave
without I'm talking here and that is the
plans for a rocket ship to be able to
blast off off this planet but before I
would even do that I have to go down in
the depths I have to find a cure for the
core R virus I have to disable the
enforcement platform but all of that
aside I must go back in here because I
promised that I would go back in here
before and I forgot about it in my
venture to collect the new upgrades but
now my adventure continues and I'm gonna
go straight it in the mouth of Reaper
territory once again but I'm gonna go
and I'm gonna find exactly that which I
need to be able to get in here and if
I'm not mistaken I might need a
propulsion cannon to be able to do that
but before I do that oh my god I don't
remember the damage being that extensive
holy [ __ ] look at all the birds oh look
at my poor framerate its dismal I gotta
go quiet right now because we are in the
thick uber territory I may have put on a
few new brave faces here and I'm gonna
not piss my pants
because I'm pretty sure if I'm not
mistaken here if I'm not mistaken I do
believe I am in the thick of it but it
seems like I just so happened to be
escaping certain doom and I'll be able
to get in there
I don't remember there being that much
volcanic activity
alright well we're gonna go down anyway
because we're gonna see what the Frick
is going buddy
Hidy Hidy Hidy ho ah yes this is
comforting I sure do love all the things
that are happening down here so you
can't see me right you don't you don't
know I'm here I'm silently running oh
I'm gonna take the long way around if
that guy's gonna stay clear of me hey
buddy boo you're so elegant and
beautiful and also okay he's just gone
there alright he's just he's just gone
that's wonderful too I guess
and I can get the cure and I can get out
of here then maybe just maybe just maybe
I'll see my friends and family once
again but that's if I get the disease
cured because otherwise that's just
gonna dislike disintegrate my DNA and
I'm gonna be just uh a mushy lump of
nothingness as I go into the into the
world whoa where am I
wait a minute this looks huh this is
different no this is way different
okie dokie
so I'll just Park this bad boy right
there
oh and also I forgot about that I forgot
about the nose here god it is spooky
with all the red lighting in here
so I want to thank uh whoa where's my
let's go we got Patrick Norris who said
the marbled melons you planted are fully
grown to actually make them work hit
them with a knife and eat the other the
one you hit will give you seeds what you
did just did was like planting a fully
grown watermelon into the ground to grow
instead of planting the seeds in other
words I was ignorant it didn't do it I
was supposed to do but anyway also we
got toxic Britain who said who who who's
who's lamenting the fact that now that
my big box berry is breakable I seem to
have I seemed a goddamn want to smash it
up against every single thing I come
across and when I got here I came
through a really fun field of fish and
it was just non-stop peppering my entire
big box Barry this little fish corpses
bouncing up the surface my body slammed
them a little too hard and they just
couldn't take it and then finally
there's Audrey Pelican Helicon oh who
said you can pick up seats shredder poop
and use it for fertilizer
nah I'm one to try new things I am I
really am but I just thought I don't
want to do that I just I really don't
want to do that that sounds that sounds
goddamn awful I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna do that anyway before I go in
there I'm going to make an R uphold a
pro a propulsion cannon I think that's
what I'm going to make and here we go
this is the Ben
I could do both but I don't eat both I
just need the propulsion cannon for now
this is the benefit of having a goddamn
boat with every goddamn material you
could possibly want but unfortunately
I'm running out soon but I have this for
now and now it's all when I need it so
I'm gonna grab this right here to
probably bring one of the big honking
heavy batteries shouldn't I oh that's a
fakie wakie battery if I ever saw one
all right fine then you're gonna get
away with it but not for long cuz I'm
gonna put things at storage over here
alright flip I blue oh no so I'm gonna
eat some marble melons I'm gonna need
some potatoes too cuz I got a whole
bunch of goodies over here I actually I
split them up already and I've already
got like a whole bunch of these bad boys
and these are so nutritious Oh
scrumptious Oh
let me wash that down with a bit of piss
shall I Oh hmm delectable
huh not really but anyway one more end
blap and then a little more piss and oh
my god for the first time in ages I have
topped off my food and water and now I
can finally go in there with a clear
mind and a keep calm Kitty poster and
that is truly all that matters in life
so let's go in here
and not waste another gosh down second
here because this is this is remarkably
different they used to have a huge ramp
that just led upwards and upwards but
now it's just
yeah you missed me up a notch but now
it's just this one door here oh stop it
why whoa hey you want to get why would
hey get some flour in you through no how
about this Subaru oh that takes up a lot
of power
oh wow oh we gosh
I didn't even need to bring a fire
extinguisher they were gonna provide one
as is oh oh wait am i stupid wait am i
stupid and there was just oh did I just
not go ahh
I just didn't go the same way I've gone
before oh I see how this is I see how
this is okay I was just uh I was just a
bit of a doof ah oh hey maybe I wasn't
ow
again oh why oh they did I still there
oh I'm indeed I'm an idiot I was wrong
there goes right there I'm stupid here I
was going like oh my god everything's
different and yet I was just being an
idiot cuz I went the way that I was
supposed to go now won't you know that
Hey oh oh
have I opened this before no I haven't
what forward by Robin Eckland all the
good things in life are commodities we
trade love just as we buy and sell stock
we engage in human relationships when
there is fair exchange of value support
motivation affection nothing good is
ever free if ever physical good in the
Federation came from a single supplier
it would constitute dangerous monopoly
personal relationships are the same it
is important for people to get what they
need from multiple sources if a person
finds a better source of the goods they
require they are not wronging their
original supplier by changing their
purchase Arrangements if one member of
relationship should feel threatened or
jealous they must look at their own
business model and ask whether it is
performing competitively there's always
room for improvement
Robin Eklund is a dick Robin Eklund is a
sack of [ __ ] yeah sure
human relationships are just commodities
to be bought and sold emotions be damned
Wow that is real douchey of that guy but
man I don't know what whoa hey what did
I just see up what is what excuse me
what what are you what are you
what what what I got a toy
what's that Gorge I love it I can't hold
it but I love it I will love it forever
in a day oh I love its red skeleton oh I
love it I love it oh I love it
ok so now we just got this mysterious
locked door not that one huh apparently
there's no code to this door man what
what the what the what the wiki is
telling me is that behind this door is
where the aurora stuff that I need is
the rocket launch the everything it's
apparently right behind this door and I
don't know how to open it I don't even
know if there is a way to open it
because apparently it doesn't have a
code now there are multiple codes that
you get from the data pads that around
here one of them is 1 4 5 4 yeah the
other is 1 8 6 9 which doesn't work
there's a lab code 4 6 4 8 3 but none of
them tell what's behind this door the
only way for me to get in this door
would be to activate a debug command
that would allow me to slip right by and
that would constitute as cheating but I
think I think the ends justify the means
in this one I'm not cheating to make any
progress out giving myself a little
advantage to open this door which can't
be opened by any other means there is
literally no way to legitimately open
this door I want to make that very clear
which is the only reason I'm about to do
what I'm about to do I hope you all can
forgive me in the name
of progress there just so happens to be
a command called unlock doors which
unlocks all doors in the Aurora and
considering that this is the only door
that is still locked this should work on
this door
alright unlock doors it worked amazingly
it worked so let's see if it was worth
it
ominous oh I just pissed myself
anticipation or a PDA first what this
PDA is nothing new
I guess the PDA wouldn't have anything
considering it's not technically
supposed to be here yet but oh man oh
wow
it's an Aurora miniature before it got
all blowed oh that's so cool oh it's so
cool can i bind this one oh I can't I
wish I just could hold it but apparently
this is the rocket launch pad no it's
not what is that what is that supposed
to be
Aurora long-range communications relay
offline average long range transmission
eight hours this is an emergency
distress call Aurora is on a collision
course with planet for 546 be sending
all available environmental data please
respond with rescue solution altaira HQ
this is all Terra HQ this may be our
only communication window we can't send
a rescue ship all the way out there so
Aurora you're just gonna have to meet us
halfway we've uploaded blueprints to the
ship's computer black box data shows the
high-security terminal in the captains
quarters is still functional the code
should be blabbetty blabbetty blue buddy
blue when you download the blueprints
you should find plans for an escape ship
we calculate will be capable of breaking
orbit and getting you back to the
nearest phase game it's designed to use
materials you can find in the sit - but
it's going to need a hell of a power
source you may need to salvage parts
the Aurora's reactor or come up with
something more creative we'll be sure to
blank well there you have it this is the
this is the this is the thing that's
supposed to give you the code for the
blueprints for the rocket ship in the
captains quarters
you guys weren't lying about that you
guys definitely weren't lying about that
that was 100% true what this door's
unlocked
oh it's empty I'm just gonna close that
up because I feel like I shouldn't have
been in there in the first place
so with that being said I'm now gonna
disable the console because I am not
cheating to get myself any resources but
that I feel wasn't interesting enough
venture to be worth it I don't feel good
about it I don't I honestly do not but
it is interesting that that is not
that's nuts but that's not supposed to
be that way
Oh God IRA I have repercussions far
beyond what I comprehended Oh No so
supposedly I just found this out
supposedly that room is eventually going
to be the captains quarters and then the
plans will be on the terminal and then
that little snippet of information will
be on the PDA that was supposed to be on
the bed but that is all there is on the
Aurora for now I will not be able to get
the plans for the rocket ship and that's
for its own good because I wouldn't have
been able to do anything with them
anyway even when I was doing the
experimental mode or whatever you want
to call the the [ __ ] mode where you
just play around with your diddly-doo
and then yeah you know you try to have
fun I guess I don't know what I'm
talking about anymore but I was playing
around in creative mode and even then
when I tried to build the rocket ship it
didn't work so I'm thinking that the
rocket ship is just not ready for this
version of the game but it will be ready
someday and when that day comes I will
be ready but I don't want to waste you
guys as time on all this don't think
that this was a fruitless venture
because I've got one more thing that I'm
going to be doing in this episode
oh and freedom freedom with a bunch of
crab [ __ ] okay so now that we got
that underway we still have something
that we got to do I mean that is a
revelation and it is the one thing that
got me too cheap in this game and I
didn't want to I swear to you I did not
want to but had to do it for the sake of
seeing where that was in terms of
development and and thankfully you know
I don't have to go and build a rocket
ship right now which is kind of a bit of
a resource heavy endeavor but what I do
have is a bug Laden to the brim with
resources titanium out the wazoo
not as much quartz as I would like but
I've got a fair bit so with that be oh
[ __ ] I just chunk oh let me just make
sure I'm not about to be attacked here I
just want to be certain about this I'm
pretty far out and what I want to do is
I want to get down into those depths at
least to the Lost River because some
people seem to be
nicholae about the concept that there
might just maybe be a ghost Leviathan
lurking among the bones of that even
bigger greater ancient Leviathan of days
yonder past so I'm gonna skedaddle on
over there I'll meet you on the other
side also I'll meet you when I hit all
those fish on the way hey it's all those
fish I was telling you about sorry sorry
sorry that was a big one i body slam
that pologize for nothing
oh here we go sorry that's a new noise
that'sthat's the noise I haven't heard
before that's a that's a that's a
definitely a new one and I'm uh not a
hundred percent too happy about that but
that is that is what that is
oh those noises are less than fun oh hi
why why are you here well you're way off
path you're way off path are you here to
give me some fertilizer to fertilize my
crops cuz that's awfully nice of you I
think I Karen's been a while I know I
know it's been a while but you know I've
been busy with a lot of [ __ ]
apparently man this there's a ton of
good stuff here what [ __ ] good thing I
stopped by there's this goodies out the
wazoo Oh quarts yes please so that's
about everything I think we've done a
clean sweep with pretty much everything
that we need we got more copper we got
more gold we got pretty much all
followed in this bad boy of already
fullness like every almost every single
one of these uh these lockers that I
made I never thought I'd do it I never
my entire life thought I'd actually be
filling these lockers but almost every
Locker in this entire ship is stuffed
with materials so it's time to stop
delaying like a little [ __ ] that I
it's time to go deep down into that
ocean ah yes
oh my god that's impossible to see holy
[ __ ] I think Oh God
oh that is messing with my brain but I
think I'm going the right way
oh boy I know I know I know I know it's
okay it's all good it's all good we just
got a Turner fire what the [ __ ]
fine fire I barely tapped any of those
things I got another one over give me
give me that give it i frickin oh god
they're gearing up the dubstep come on
there we go oh boy oh boy I would not
Bose know anything but those whoa
where's the fire where's more fire term
or fire get down the goddamn ladder
[ __ ] fire extinguished yes traumas
initiate all right didn't mean to do
that
that was just a problem of
maneuverability now we're gonna go in
here
God how did I go near the first time oh
yeah my thing was indestructible and
didn't matter if I hit anything sorry
you fit is not my fault nod my that's
clearly not my fault clearly that is a
hundred percent on you Oh morning my god
ah god dammit I forgot about you [ __ ]
[ __ ] I seem to be stuck on some
weight sonar and activate the shield up
nananana I got my shields on whatever
the hell that's gonna do for me
apparently nothing cuz I'm out of power
there we go
Jesus just don't be a douche bag is all
I ask of you all I ask of you guys oh
and we're good you're good you're good
you're good
uh sorry you're good and a blip BLAP
Lord be blue but I think we made it
through I can hardly believe it Frick
that was way too stressful but we made
it we made it into the Lost River once
again we are finally back down I'm gonna
save we're finally back down in the
depths the depths of hell maybe I do not
know but I want to see I want to see
firsthand if there is in fact anything
down here and if there is where it lurks
and if it means me any hostility because
if it do I'm screwed if it don't I'm
boned I'm I'm going I'm good I'm good
I'm probably gonna be good
maybe just maybe
ah so quick I got like chills man mouse
there's no joke creepy that's so weird
again because now it's a threat cuz I
even down here even if that thing isn't
down here and I'm hoping it's not but
even if that's not down here then
there's still all the bony bastards they
want to take bites out of my ass so I
got a stay real silent oh hi
okay no initial signs of any ghosts
Leviathan down here although it might
just be invisible like a ghost would be
and I wouldn't notice it
uh alrighty then ok I don't see nothing
well the whales of the Damned are
comforting once more but I don't want to
be here oh yeah I've taken a quite a
beating just getting down here I got to
pop off and rest and repair soon but
we'll all right but it looks ok looks ok
it looks like there's no ghosts
Leviathan thankfully I don't know what
those black triangles are some sort of
fish I guess but it looks simple sorry
whatever I just did
sorry little but anyway it looks like
I'm finally back down here and
thankfully no ghosts Leviathan yet but
that thing is got to be coming soon so
that's all the time I got for this
episode here thank you everybody so much
for watching next step is to go even
deeper back down into the depths of Hell
and see once and for all
what we can do about this sea dragon so
thank you again everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye
[Music]